so twitch has a stalking problem and i'm
not
talking about misguided fans who don't
realize that it's not okay
to show up to your house for an
impromptu meet and greet
no what i'm talking about here are
multiple streamers dealing with targeted
harassment
death threats violated restraining
orders and full-on physical
assault
[Music]
so on thursday september 9th twitch
streamer bx bullet posted a twit longer
where she details her experiences with a
person she alleges
is a serial harasser and stalker she
calls him by name matthew brockett
online he goes by spectypoo and from now
on i'm going to be referring to him as
specty according to the twit longer the
problem started when bx bullet filed a
police report against specte alleging
that he was using
quote his org to lure kids into a
discord server where he was being
sexually inappropriate with them
sharing pornographic websites and images
and possibly grooming them for
exploitation
end quote now the org that bx bullet is
referring to
is inception esports which specty
founded and the report she filed to her
local police department which was made
public last week details an alleged
history of sexual misconduct which
she claims involved minors many of the
allegations stem from the inception
esports partner discord server which at
one point had over 3 500 members
and allegedly had multiple instances of
racist and homophobic conversations
and the whole reason that bx bullet
knows who specti is
is that at one point she was signed to
inception esports as a just chatting
streamer it's a 24-page report
documenting in detail
with screenshots videos and private
conversations a litany of allegations
against specte
from his time running three different
esports organizations
most recently with inception esports
according to
bx bullet specty somehow found out about
the report that she
filed and according to her this is when
the harassment began
and he's been coming at me with
everything he has with doxing harassment
bots threats uh tell you know telling me
he has my address
and like saying things like see you soon
or can't wait to come visit you kind of
stuff
from allegedly doxxing her repeatedly to
allegedly giving her name and address to
people that she describes as dark web
criminals
threatening to show up to where she was
on a recent trip
and even allegedly having a naked photo
of her daughter on his computer
it got to the point where bx bullet
decided to stop streaming on twitch out
of fear for her and her daughter's
safety she ran in here and she had
underwear on
um but she bolted in here and i like
lunged at her and grabbed her and
wrangled her out
and then you know i ended the stream and
as i was doing that i noticed that
somebody
who was associated with him had clipped
the incident
and i deleted it right away and i
deleted the vod
and then the next day he sent me a
message saying that he had naked
pictures of my three-year-old child
saved and he was using it to blackmail
me or to
threaten me or to say that he was going
to try to get me banned from twitch
according to her specty at one point was
banned from discord in connection to
allegations similar to what she filed in
her report
but allegedly he uses multiple different
alt accounts to remain on discord
she says that even some of his admins
have quote
email discord support trying to get his
alt accounts banned with no luck
end quote now bx bullet says that she's
spoken to multiple different lawyers and
that due to differing
state laws if she wanted to do something
legally
she'd have to take him to federal court
which would be extraordinarily expensive
she also says that she's reached out to
her local authorities multiple different
times but that they haven't been very
helpful
now i also reached out to specty for
comment and to get his perspective on
this situation
and here's what he had to say it's three
years ago and that's no excuse for
anything but i don't even remember what
i did three weeks ago
so my language and talking to people
i'm not asking every single person what
their age is on discord and i don't
think people do that normally
and i i watch i watch other youtube
channels like
uh like mcnasty or like boardie and
people like that and they're talking to
people
like like the same way and no one has a
problem with it i get why but no one
raised awareness back then saying hey
this is a real big problem you shouldn't
be talking to the miners like this and
i know it's not the right thing to do
but like
being in gaming and it's really really a
toxic
environment in some games and this is
what specty had to say when it came to
the allegations of targeted harassment
towards bx bullet online
so i had the address they took it and
they did
whatever with it i mean they they found
everything
more they found more about her than than
i even have i knew
i knew what they were i didn't know how
hard they were going to act on it
i didn't know i didn't know hey if i
give this person this information are
they going to go
really really hard on her or they're
just going to go look at it and be like
yeah whatever
now what we talked about here is only a
fraction of what's alleged in bx bullets
report and while this might be the
latest instance of stalking and online
harassment in the world of twitch
unfortunately it's far from the only one
a few months ago
sweet anita who's a popular twitch
streamer with tourette syndrome went
public with her own experiences dealing
with targeted harassment i had a stalker
they've been stalking me for quite a few
months actually
um they've been coming to my house
they've been sleeping
pretty much in my backyard watching the
house and uh
the other day some shopkeepers had to
intervene
and kind of hold him back while he
chased after me
according to anita this person slept in
her backyard multiple times
peeked through her mail slot while she
was home physically
assaulted her and violated the
restraining order she filed against him
multiple times it apparently got so bad
that anita said she feared for her life
this person would bang on her door for
hours at a time and would constantly
send her death threats he threatened to
kill me
and the police response has been
incredibly underwhelming
after he assaulted me i had a witness i
had a lot of evidence
and the police did nothing she goes on
to say that when the police eventually
went to talk to this person about the
alleged assault he was on his way to see
her and he allegedly had a knife on him
after months of anita pushing for
something to happen
she says that recently the police
pressed charges and this guy was given a
suspended sentence of two months of
prison
and basically a suspended sentence is
where you're found guilty of whatever
you've been charged with but you
probably won't be spending any time in
prison
the press charges was talking he's been
banned from visiting my town
so he's going to be escorted back to his
guest house to collect his things
and then he has to just stay out of town
now recently anita published a youtube
video
talking about all of this while also
interviewing streamers chocobars
destiny sushi kitty and caseytron about
their experiences dealing with online
harassment
i left and i thought right that is it
i'm done with this guy
forever that's when it turned into
stalking it's been ongoing still
happening
for uh two and a half years now it's
like they
just get off on just
making you your life miserable like this
one guy who's
harassing me now that's been harassing
me for years like since 2014.
the video touches on a lot of different
topics streamers fearing for their
safety
the lack of response from the
authorities or twitch and just a general
sense of helplessness
chocobars in particular has been vocal
about her experiences with online
harassment
at one point tweeting that she fears
that she might die at the hands of her
alleged stalker
because nobody can do anything about it
until something actually happens
police said they can't do anything
because he hasn't really threatened my
life
mine is just like an annoying mosquito
fly that just
hates me i've even like talked to
lawyers to see what they can do
but if i wanted to do the lawyer route
um i would have to pay like
20 plus thousand dollars now when it
comes to twitch they haven't said or
done
much although they did pledge to review
and update their harassment and hateful
conduct policies back in june
during a wave of sexual misconduct
allegations and that's the big question
here
we all know that something needs to
change but outside of twitch working
with the police in the most extreme
cases what does twitch do here bx bullet
who you'll remember is the woman we
started this story talking about
says that she's reported her situation
to twitch over 50
times and that she's never received
anything other than a standard email
saying well we got your email one
notable exception to this where
something was actually
done about a case of targeted harassment
is the recent leafy pokemate situation
after weeks of youtube videos about
pokemane which were full of remarks
about her appearance and speculation on
her personal life
leafy was actually permanently banned
from youtube
for violating the platform's harassment
policies and what's important to
understand here is that leafy was banned
not long after youtube updated its
creator on creator harassment policy
which they originally rolled out in
2019.
and when it comes to violating youtube's
policies it's very similar to twitch in
that regard it's a three strike and
you're out system according to youtube's
ceo this updated policy tries to draw a
distinction between
quote creators criticizing each other
and being a part of this free speech and
open ideas
and then where do you draw the line
where do they cross the line when it's
no longer just ideas
but they're criticizing them as a person
end quote
this is an important distinction to make
where is the line between commentary
youtubers commenting on other youtubers
and
harassment
[Music]
you